hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play purgatorium
now this is a game that's made by the
same guy that made ex mortis it's also a
flash game which I've been meaning to
get back to all the flash games that you
all suggested for me but with the
computer switch I lost the list so if
you guys can send me suggestions for
horror flash games or interesting flash
games that you would like me to play
then please send them my way
ya left let Loeffler web-design i think
it was a been left little er left Lee
Air Lift they are I don't know anyway
it's a shorter game it says but it's
supposed to be really good purgatory on
deed so let's see what we're getting
ourselves into
cuz you know I love these atmospheric
low games okay it's never good when
you're starting out on a uh in a child's
room because child children are
diabolical all right what do we get
I'll wind up the chair suddenly moving
by itself it's just standing there
oh hello hi hello a headless lady that's
nice oh oh oh that's just a doll I Holly
crap I thought that was a real dead baby
huh why me not a real dumb game and
never mind
Oh God look at its eyes ha ha hey dolls
dolls and mannequins what on earth is
something it's got blood - so how I get
huh Oh God Oh
oh shut up baby Oh
one particular doll that is very
disconcerting yet oddly familiar yeah no
kidding
what is this your childhood room your
father was a murdering maniac that that
headless woman was the mob ah oh hi
buddy hi well you don't have any
commentary on that they left us stain on
my window better bust out the non-brand
window cleaner than I need okay that
door here I can't open oh is that a
barbecue fork ha ha ah I could probably
use this fork Oh God's normal yeah
normal okay you don't recognize the face
maybe oh it's a head from the woman oh
okay she's got like I don't know what
what that is coming out of the base of
her neck
all right ah short out the power I don't
want to do that why would I want to
short out the power how would I want to
do that oh hey on the music box has
stopped playing that haunting song it's
all way it's odd I'm starting to feel a
heightened anxiety
I felt worse with the song playing so
I'm just fine right now thank you very
much
I'm also recording this on a brand new
record a screen recording software I'll
let you know what it is if I get a good
endorsement of it glowing review I don't
think that oh I got here baby
don't turn the room dark like the room
starts to get dark when I stared staring
it then oh no like the Brum breeze oh
god that is creepy whoever makes this is
like really really good at doing it what
am I supposed to do here I got the
barbecue fork I'm assuming that okay
what am I missing here - you might be
able to pick it with a long a small thin
object how about the fork I can't
maybe not hang on there's got to be
something with a chair whoo no whoo hoo
Winnie them I used to have a yeah when I
was young
aha this is the guy's been childhood
bedroom the only fond childhood memory
that I can take with me to my grave just
a window to vast oblivion of darkness
going to smell recently soiled oh you
crapped your pants man
uh whoo hey ah ah ha ha ha oh oh oh
is there something in there
okay can I pick the door now
I don't tell me at all what did how does
that help me
the door is bricked in who bricks me in
here why why this is called purgatorium
because it's my eternal punishment for
doing something I guess my turtle
punishment is trying to figure out how
there's a whole new mom kid hang on
there's a hole in the wall why can't I
why is there a brick missing that's what
I'm asking why is that it's blood wall
to the window blood on the wall that
doesn't it shorted out wait
aha I that only worked then I don't know
okay see you
let's see what's through here Oh a
tombstone don don don grave on and my
child and wife dead blood on my hands
breaking up the doorway what the hell is
happening here
my family slaughtered police were unable
to save a woman in her eight month old
son from her mentally ill husband bill
Rydell today as he bricked his family
into a room and proceeded to mutilate
them with a variety of household tools
including a barbecue fork authorities
arrived on the scene to find the house
burdock - [ __ ] yeah ah within middle of
a word
I like swallowed my tongue on that one
Jesus Christ huh okay alright I don't
know that looks like a Chinese mask or
something like um you know one of those
Chinese demon masks ha ha oh is it is
that the end
oh that's it oh okay well whoops yeah
that was pretty damn short but either
way that was still pretty good that last
one got me but I mean I was in the
middle of reading something I was trying
to get the story heaven young screwed me
over buddy
so anyways Father that was the father
okay so that was pretty good but
obviously very short so if you guys have
any other ideas of other games that I
could play that are like these or fun or
really interesting quirky fun flash
games I would be definitely interested
so whatever you got
my way and as always we know thank you
so much for watching I gotta say that
for good can taste from what videos that
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video bye hey Mark you I see
something funny oh my back
well whatever whatever okay